pour le sur le fond on peut dire que cet
amendement fait que les choses soient
moins pires que pire mais l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes elle est
avérée elle était verrée aussi au moment
de au moment de la retraite
il y a un écart de 28% sur les droits à
la retraite entre les hommes et les
femmes et quand on prend en compte
uniquement les droits directs et pas les
droits dérivés cet écart monte à 41%.
donc il y a une vraie difficulté et j'en
viens à toujours cette ce problème que
notre collègue fièrent à évoqué tout à
l'heure
vous avez dit mais cette réforme c'est
le bon sens parce que on vit plus
longtemps et donc d'une certaine façon
il n'y a pas besoin de sortir de
Polytechnique pour comprendre qu'il faut
faire plus rien n'est plus faux rien
n'est plus faux parce que encore une
fois je vous le répète vous raisonnez
sur des moyennes et en statistique ça
n'a pas de sens la moyenne est une
valeur générale ce qui compte c'est
l'écart à la moyenne et l'écart à la
moyenne il est complètement différent en
fonction du sexe et en fonction de la
catégorie sociale et en fonction du
revenu donc faire comme si la moyenne
concernait tout le monde c'est
complètement faux certains sont
directement touchés et impactés et faire
croire comme le gouvernement que cette
réforme est une réforme de bon sens
c'est justement un non-sens statistique
une erreur politique et une erreur
sociale
[Musique]